ah
un espacio similar a este en el que yo
acabo de simular que duermo es para
millones de personas en el mundo lo más
parecido a un hogar
os imagináis cómo es vivir en la calle
os imagináis cómo es no tener un lugar
al que volver después del día un espacio
de seguridad un espacio de tranquilidad
donde poder hacer cosas tan básicas como
comer como dormir como hace arte como
guardar tus cosas y tus pertenencias un
espacio donde poder tener tu intimidad
un espacio donde poder tener tu vida
proyectar tus sueños construir tu
proyecto vital
pues bien hoy en el mundo hay millones
de personas que no tienen no disponen de
un lugar para vivir
este círculo rojo quiero que sea hoy
también una llamada de atención una
alerta sobre una crisis global una gran
crisis que recorre el mundo una crisis
de la que no se habla la crisis de la
vivienda una crisis que está truncando
las expectativas de vida de millones de
personas y en la que hablamos muy
poquito
y la que nos cuesta ver y reconocer pero
que impacta en la vida de la gente
porque cuántas personas viven en la
calle hoy el día en el mundo cuántas
en el mundo viven 150 millones de
personas incluso más
en europa tenemos más de 5 millones de
personas viviendo en la calle
por ejemplo en gran bretaña tenemos más
de 300.000 en alemania casi un millón y
en españa' que pasó en españa en españa
viven y duermen en la calle más de 31
mil personas
el principal problema también que
tenemos con esta crisis es que faltan
datos y lo que no se conoce no existe y
si no existe es muy difícil resolverlo
por eso digo que esta crisis es una
crisis global y es una crisis que no
siempre sabemos ver
igual estáis pensando que estoy
exagerando bueno está hablando de crisis
no es para tanto que exagerado una
crisis global recorre el mundo
mirad simplemente en el distrito de los
ángeles que seguro que nos buena porque
lo hemos visto mil veces en las
películas en eeuu
bueno pues hoy día en ese distrito hay
60 mil personas viviendo en las calles
en una sola calle de los ángeles hay más
de 3000 y eso está pasando hoy esto está
siendo emergencia nacional en eeuu y la
cnn va con helicópteros a conectar en
directo con lo que está pasando porque
estas personas no encuentran una
solución a sus problemas de vivienda
por eso digo que es una crisis pero
miremos hacia europa qué pasa en europa
en europa las cifras del problema de las
personas sin hogar están creciendo en
los últimos años creciendo muchísimo con
cifras de dos y hasta tres dígitos y
esto nos pasa en españa pasa en francia
pasa en alemania ciudades como londres
parís berlín bruselas donde día tras día
hay personas que se ven obligadas a
vivir en las calles
no en todos los países hay uno que no en
finlandia no pasa en finlandia pasa
justo lo contrario están consiguiendo
reducir el problema del sinhogarismo
luego vuelve volveré sobre ello y
contaré por qué y cuál es la clave para
que lo puedan estar solucionando y hablo
de crisis porque una de cada diez
personas en españa se ha encontrado
alguna vez sin un lugar donde vivir y
ser así en el futuro son datos de un
estudio muy reciente que se ha
presentado hace muy poquitos días a
nivel europeo
hablo de crisis porque día tras día
seguimos viendo personas que se ven
abocadas a la calle por desahucios por
no poder pagar la hipoteca pero es que
también por no poder pagar el alquiler
crisis las personas se ven expulsadas de
los barrios de las ciudades de sus
viviendas
las personas no pueden hacer su proyecto
vital
por eso hablo de crisis
porque en el fondo la vivienda que es la
vivienda como la queremos entender
la vivienda como un espacio básico la
vivienda desde un fin social la vivienda
como derecho la vivienda como un hogar
o entendemos la vivienda y queremos
entender la vivienda como una mercancía
mirad lo que está pasando en los últimos
años es que la vivienda ha pasado a
convertirse en una mercancía en un
mercado y se ha ido olvidando la función
social de la vivienda su fin básico es
tan así que las viviendas se compran y
se venden en lotes hay empresas que
especulan con las viviendas a nivel
global en mercados globales habréis oído
hablar de los fondos buitres
mirad antiguamente se especulaba en
estos mercados con cereales con petróleo
con productos básicos
que tenían valor esto está pasando hoy
día con las viviendas
y digo esto porque es importante
conectarlo con los efectos que tiene
sobre la vida de las personas porque en
el fondo es de lo que estamos hablando y
es lo que nos importa como sociedad
fijaros astaná si esta crisis
que los precios del alquiler se han
duplicado en los últimos años por no
hablar ya de los precios de la compra de
vivienda si a esto le sumamos el
fenómeno de la precariedad laboral
de la explotación de las dificultades
para encontrar un trabajo y de los bajos
salarios
tenemos la tormenta perfecta porque
resulta que para poder afrontar los
costes de vivienda tenemos un problema
ya que no podemos disponer más que de
una pequeña parte de nuestro salario
para nuestras necesidades básicas todos
se lo comen los gastos de la vivienda
qué ocurre si no tenemos trabajo o si lo
tenemos precario o inseguro
nos va a ser muy difícil a partir de
ahora poder garantizar ese espacio vital
donde vivir
de hecho la vivienda hoy día se ha
convertido en el principal elemento de
inclusión social si recordáis
antiguamente bueno no hace mucho era el
empleo el trabajo tienes trabajo no lo
tienes lo tienes precario
te han hecho indefinido que sueldo
tienes la diferencia fundamental entre
formar parte y no formar parte de la
sociedad hoy en día ya no es tanto el
empleo como la vivienda
tienes vivienda o no tienes vivienda
pero ya no hablamos en propiedad si no
puedes acceder a una vivienda has
encontrado buena vivienda en alquiler
donde a qué precio
no estoy seguro de cuánto tiempo podrá
quedarme si me subirán el alquiler
si mi edificio será comprado por un
fondo y tarde o temprano me obligarán a
marcharme las personas se ven obligadas
a dejar las viviendas a dejar los
barrios a dejar las ciudades habréis
escuchado hablar sobre el fenómeno de la
gentrificación que vacía las ciudades y
convierte edificios pisos y viviendas
prácticamente en hoteles y en espacios
de generación de riqueza y de
especulación
mirad lo residencial es político hoy más
que nunca porque que esto sea así no es
como ahora que hace calor ahí fuera
porque es una cuestión meteorológica que
estas cosas esas cosas pasen no es
porque hoy hace frío mañana llueve o
hace calor no es algo natural que esto
sea así es una decisión política
porque las cosas podrían no ser así y
ser de otra manera es decir no tenemos
que conformarnos con que estas cosas
pasen porque podrían no pasar
yo lo que planteó hoy lo que propongo y
lo que os pregunto es queremos entender
la vivienda como un derecho humano como
un derecho básico es desde ahí desde
donde yo os propongo mirar este fenómeno
y mirar este problema y es desde ahí
desde donde yo os propongo conectar esto
que os cuento con lo que le pasa a las
personas que os encontráis en la calle
si el problema es así el problema de las
personas que están en la calle se llama
sinhogarismo este palabro que a veces
habréis escuchado supongo porque
últimamente se habla mucho de él
y quiero hablar del sinhogarismo porque
el sinhogarismo es el fenómeno por el
cual miles de personas en el mundo no
pueden acceder a un derecho fundamental
como es el derecho de la vivienda y
quiero poner el foco sobre el problema
porque porque habitualmente hemos puesto
el foco sobre las personas hemos puesto
el foco sobre un problema que hemos
pensado que era individual bueno hemos
visto a la persona si es que la vemos
vivir en la calle porque muchas son
invisibles a nuestros ojos y hemos
pensado bueno será un conjunto de malas
decisiones ha tenido mala suerte algo
habrá hecho mal
como decía mi madre hay donde te ves por
tu mala cabeza
o también podemos pensar bueno está en
la calle porque quiere mirar
he trabajado ocho años en una ong que
trabaja con personas sin hogar lo puedo
decir la fundación rais a la que tengo
mucho cariño y no he conocido ni una
sola persona que me diga que su proyecto
vital que su sueño era vivir en la calle
ninguna de verdad
con lo cual yo lo que os pido es por
favor cuando veamos una persona viviendo
en la calle durmiendo en la calle
pensemos en por qué y en todo lo que
está detrás
evitemos criminalizar a las personas y
culpabilizar las de su situación
fijar si hemos fijaros si hemos rebajado
tanto
digamos la calidad humana de las
personas que viven en la calle que hoy
día nos sorprenden
actuaciones como devolver el dinero que
una persona se encuentra auxiliar a un
herido después de un ataque terrorista
como vimos en su momento un mendigo o un
homeless auxilia a un enfermo en un
ataque terrorista pero qué esperabais
que no la auxiliar es que una persona
por el mero hecho de vivir en la calle
se la ve despojada de de su condición
humana
de verdad esto todavía nos sigue
sorprendiendo y luego tenemos la otra
visión que es la visión romántica el
homeless que toca el piano y alegra a
los viandantes la persona sin hogar que
es artista
mirad las personas que viven en la calle
son personas que viven en la calle y es
desde ahí
os propongo entender esto como una
vulneración de derechos humanos que
afecta además a derechos tan básicos que
van más allá de la vivienda y que están
muy relacionados entre sí y además así
lo marca nuestra constitución española
voy a hablar de cuatro derechos básicos
que están muy relacionados con el
problema de vivir en la calle
el primero es obvio lo estáis pensando
es el derecho de la vivienda
este derecho no se cumple y esto impacta
la vida de la gente impacta tanto que el
44 por ciento de las personas que se
encuentran sin hogar llevan más de 3
años en la calle no es ni un día ni dos
ni tres no es más de tres pero es que
personas que llevan nueve y diez años y
no consiguen salir
pero es que al mismo tiempo la gran
parte de las plazas de los albergues
están destinadas a una estancia temporal
de dos o tres días a una emergencia con
lo cual hay algo que no cuadra otro
derecho que está relacionado con este es
la salud os imagináis lo difícil que es
cuidar la salud desde la calle cómo te
vas a recuperar de una convalecencia
médica cómo vas a recibir quimioterapia
si estás viviendo y durmiendo en la
calle es absolutamente imposible por eso
decimos que la calle mata porque la
calle mata a las personas
fijaros el 30 por ciento de las personas
que viven en la calle sufre de
enfermedades graves y las personas que
llevan tiempo en la calle tienen 30 años
menos de esperanza de vida
hay un tercer derecho básico que está
relacionado y que es el derecho al
trabajo el artículo 35 como sería buscar
trabajo desde la calle no es que las
personas sin hogar necesitan un empleo
claro y para ir al empleo donde te
duchas donde planchas tu camisa cómo te
conectas para poder enviar un currículum
cómo te alimentas donde descansas cuándo
vuelves del trabajo es absolutamente
imposible por no decir muy difícil y aún
así el 52% de las personas sin hogar
están buscando un empleo pero fijaros
hoy podemos encontrar personas sin
vivienda y con empleo el 16 por ciento
de las personas sin hogar en barcelona
tienen trabajo pero no tienen donde
vivir porque un empleo ya no te
garantiza poder pagar la vivienda y esto
es un drama
y por último un derecho que es
fundamental y es el derecho a la vida el
derecho a la integridad el derecho a no
recibir un trato inhumano o degradante
porque porque las personas que viven en
la calle son víctimas y son francos y de
anna de muchísimos delitos agresiones
insultos
y en muchas ocasiones y por desgracia
hasta la muerte esto es tan importante
que se ha llegado a acuñar un término
que se denomina aporofobia que estoy
seguro que habéis escuchado alguna vez
os suena si a verme me levanta jce la
mano quien haya escuchado alguna vez el
término aporofobia aporofobia que ha
sido admitido por la rae y ha sido
palabra del año hace muy poquito es el
término que hace referencia a los bueno
a la situación y a la discriminación que
sufren las personas por su razón de
pobreza de carencia de recursos en este
caso de vivir en la calle
el 47% de las personas sin hogar han
sido víctimas de algún delito o alguna
agresión y la gran parte no se denuncian
porque piensan que no sirven para nada
cuando digo que en la calle matta es que
la calle te mata o bien por la salud o
por la falta de acceso a la salud o bien
porque te matan de una pedrada te
prenden fuego en un cajero o
desgraciadamente bueno amaneces en un
momento dado sin vida esto luego lo
cuentan como muerte natural alguien
puede pensar que una persona que aparece
fallecida en la calle ha muerto de
muerte natural por favor pero es que
esto lo seguimos encontrando en los
periódicos que soluciones hemos dado a
este problema
muy pocas y muy poco innovadoras
básicamente albergues situaciones de
emergencia pero realmente esto no
resuelve el problema no saca a la gente
de la calle a veces nos encontramos con
innovaciones innovaciones estudiantes
que se rompen la cabeza para pensar cómo
podrían resolver el problema y lo que se
les ocurre hoy con buena intención pero
es el lugar del carrito vamos a intentar
que el carrito esté cubierto vamos a ver
las personas que viven en la calle y
tienen un problema de vivienda y lo que
necesitan no es un carrito no es un
albergue es una vivienda parece obvio
pero nos cuesta mucho relacionar ambas
cosas y sin embargo es la solución que
funciona y es la solución digamos que
tiene más impacto por eso yo os pido que
conectemos la vivienda con la situación
que tienen las personas y nos fijemos en
un método que funciona este método se
llama house in first y es el método que
están aplicando en finlandia y en otros
países desde hace tiempo para sacar a la
gente de la calle consiste en
facilitarles una vivienda desde el
primer momento con los apoyos necesarios
en la persona desde ahí pueda recuperar
su vida porque desde una vivienda es
mucho más fácil poder recuperar tu salud
tu empleo poder recuperar tu autoestima
y la relación con la comunidad es la
vivienda la que facilita el proceso de
inclusión de la gente no es de sentido
común o sí yo creo que sí pero sin
embargo no lo vemos así que podemos
hacer tomar conciencia de esto reclamar
a nuestros políticos y representantes
que den soluciones que hagan su trabajo
porque la solución existe y funciona que
este problema se tome en serio que pase
a formar parte de las políticas públicas
que colaboréis con las organizaciones
que luchan contra este problema y que
denuncien esta situación
y que podamos construir juntos y juntas
un futuro en el que no haya personas
viviendo en la calle muchas gracias